merci madame la présidente monsieur
ministre chers collègues le 15 novembre
pour être précis orange a mis fin à la
commercialisation des téléphones fixes
de réseau téléphonique commuté ce qu'on
appelle le rtc va progressivement
disparaître à compter de 2023 au
bénéfice de la technologie ip dans
l'immédiat seules les nouveaux clients
d'orange et des abonnés qui des ménages
sont concernés plusieurs question
m'interpelle monsieur le ministre et
concernent à la fois les usagers et des
entreprises je souhaiterais à ce stade
pouvoir à la fois les rassurer mais
aussi m'assurer que toutes les
dispositions seront bien prises pour
satisfaire au maintien d'un service
téléphonique de qualité à un prix
raisonnable
un disposeront de cinq ans pour faire
évoluer leurs services de téléphonie et
faire jouer la concurrence afin de
choisir l'offre de téléphonie la plus
adaptée à leurs besoins
pour autant ce temps peut aussi se
révéler bien trop court en ce qui
concerne les usages spéciaux de réseau
rtc
je pense aux facs ôter les déclarations
de deux types acte par exemple de la
télésurveillance aux alarmes d'ascenseur
ou à la têt alarme pour les personnes
isolées
ces équipements souvent indispensables
au fonctionnement des entreprises
s'appuient encore largement sur les
technologies rtc dont on sait par
ailleurs qu'elle sera inutilisable en
cas de coupure d'électricité
je crains malheureusement que cette
décision renforce et des effets de la
fracture numérique
effectivement le nouveau fixes installés
en protocole internet soient plus
exposées aux pannes car il nécessite
l'électricité alors que le réseau rtc
fonctionner même sans électricité pour
fonctionner en permanence ce nouveau
téléphone fixe a besoin d'un internet
bien sûr mais on sait aujourd'hui qu'on
à 7 5 millions de français disent ils
disposent d'internet de mauvaise qualité
de plus nous voyons que ce sont les
zones rurales qui sont majoritairement
touchés par ces soucis
la question des tarifs inquiète
légitimement la population nous avons
bien besoin a aussi monsieur muni
d'avoir des assurances
monsieur le ministre l'état est le
garant d'un service téléphonique de
qualité à un prix raisonnable orange a
été désigné opérateurs de service
universel
pouvez-vous garantir aux abonnés
particulière aux entreprises
cette muse mutation se fera dans les
conditions les plus simples elle est
plus ou moins heureuse possible
la parole est à monsieur olivier des saf
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'action et des comptes publics
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
sénateur grumier la résulte l'arrêt du
réseau de téléphonique commuté annoncé
le 15 novembre dernier constitue une
étape essentielle pour la modernisation
des infrastructures télécommunications
concrètement à partir du mois de
novembre 2018 si tout d'abord la
commercialisation de nouveaux accès sur
le rtc qui va cesser les axes existants
continueront d'être maintenue ensuite
progressivement et à partir seulement de
2022 et jusqu'en 2024
le service rtc sera arrêté par plaques
plaques qui seront annoncées cinq ans l
avance les opérateurs et accompagneront
donc les usagers dans cette transition
termes d'information et d'accompagnement
technologique
cette modernisation a pour but
d'améliorer la qualité de service de
l'utilisateur mais ne signe pas pour
autant la fin du réseau du cuivre en
effet il est essentiel que le réseau de
cuivre qui constitue pour de nombreux
concitoyens
le seul moyen de communication demeure
pleinement maintenu en attendant le
déploiement des nouveaux réseaux de
fibre optique
c'est tout le sens du mécanisme de
service universel dont le gouvernement
entend veiller à sa peine effectivité et
pour lequel l'arcep à exercer sa mission
de contrôle tout récemment dans le cadre
d'une procédure de mise en demeure à
l'encontre du groupe orange qui est en
charge du service universel pour les
usagers la fin du rtc ne signifie pas
une modification des tarifs ceux du
service universel est en fixe et
indépendamment de la technologie
utilisée par l'opérateur
merci monsieur gré millet il vous reste
quinze secondes pour une petite réponse
oui madame la prétendue et très bref
monsieur ministre il était important
d'avoir effectivement des certitudes
trop de questions se posent au niveau de
la population et des entreprises les
plus fragiles et effectivement il n'est
pas question de refuser le progrès il
est seulement question permettent aux
usagers et les plus exposés les plus
faibles de pouvoir continuer d'être bien
dans notre société